This lecture is about learning to rank.
In this lecture we are going to continue
talking about web search.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the using machine learning to
combine different features to improve
the ranking function.
So the question that we address in this
lecture is how we can combine many
features to generate a single ranking
function to optimize search results.
In the previous lectures we have talked
about a number of ways to rank
documents.
We have talked about some retrieval
models, like BM25 or query like code.
They can generate the content based
scores for matching documents
with a query and we also talked about
the link based approaches like page
rank that can give additional scores
to help us improve ranking.
Now the question now is how can we
combine all these features
and potential many other features to do
ranking and this will be very useful
for ranking web pages.
Not only just to improve accuracy, but
also to improve the robustness of the
ranking function so that it's not easy
for a spammer to just perturb a one or
a few features to promote the page.
So the general idea of learning to rank
is to use machine learning to combine
these features to optimize the weights,
different features to generate the
optimal ranking function.
So we will assume that the given a
query document appear Q and D.
We can define a number of features.
And these features can vary from
content based features such as a score
of the document with respect to the
query according to a retrieval function
such as BM25, or query likelihood or
pivot length normalization PL2 etc.
It can also be linked based score
like page rank score.
It can be also application of retrieval
models to the anchor text of the page,
those are the text descriptions of
links that point to this page.
So these can all be clues about
whether this document is relevant or
not.
We can even include a feature such as
whether the URL has a tilde '~', because
this might be indicator of homepage or
engine page.
So all these features can then be
combined together to generate the
ranking function.
The question is of course, how can we
combine them? In this approach
we simply hypothesize that the probability that
this document is relevant to this
query is
function of all these features.
So we can hypothesize
that the probability of relevance is
related to these features through a
particular form of the function that
has some parameters.
These parameters can control the
influence of different features on the
final relevance.
This is of course just a assumption
whether this assumption really makes
sense is the big question and they
have to empirically evaluate the
function.
But by hypothesising that relevance is
related to these features in a
particular way, we can then combine
these features to generate the
potentially more powerful ranking
function and more robust ranking
function.
Naturally, the next question is how do
we estimate those parameters and how do
we know which features should have a
higher weight than which features
should have lower weight, so this is the task
of training or learning, right?
So in this approach, what we will do is
to use some training data.
Those are the data that have been
judged by users so that we already know
the relevance judgments we already know
which documents should be ranked high
for which queries.
And this information can be based on
real judgments by users, or this can
also be approximated by just using
click through information where we can
assume the clicked
documents are better than the skiped
documents or clicked documents
are relevant and skiped documents are
non relevant.
So in general, we would fit such a
hypothesize the ranking function
to the training data, meaning that
we will try to optimize its retrieval
accuracy on the training data, we can
adjust these parameters to see how we can
optimize the performance of the
function on the training data in terms
of some measures such as MAP or nDCG.
So the training data would look like a
table of
tuples. Each tuple has three elements.
The query, the document and judgment.
So it looks very much like our
relevance judgments that we talked
about in evaluation of retrieval
systems.